hi everyone this is the last part in the
series of videos looking at stuff
sparring so far we've looked at sparring
with three different types of stuff foam
plus they can run the form of plastic
group for beginners however in my
opinion everyone should progress the
Wratten at some point as I think this is
the overall best for sparring although
I'll never fully replicate an oak Joe
it's the best compromise between
training with oak stuff and aspiring
safely if you want to check out the
previous videos all the links are in the
description below in this video I'll be
looking at some Aikido applications that
came out when sparring
I'll be focusing on attacks dividing
them into three categories
one-handed strikes 200 strikes and
thrusts so to start with 100 strikes in
the sparring we use quítate goronguy she
and dad say Tommy ochi that's number 11
and 12 from the sabores or solo forms
you can see cytosin say on the left
demonstrate in the Subaru their
application can also be found in the 4th
and 5th kamijou partner practice
in terms of the spiral we did both are
used in particular catotti Tommy uchi
this cropped up a lot as it delivers a
strike from the furthest distance if you
notice they also do these strikes on
both sides which isn't norm
traditionally however I think this way
of training gives an advantage as it
provides more of a balance and freedom
of movement moving on to the 200 strikes
this is a common way of striking with
the job not just an Aikido but with
other martial arts and other weapons
wilco throat one Joker in partner
practice we can see 200 strikes been
used in Aikido these clips show 5:00 and
6:00 and 10:00 and 11:00 from the third
wall Coomer Joel similarities can also
be seen when it comes to sparring
also in number 20 from the 31 kuma Joe
there's a drop in height with a two
under strike to the knee this also comes
up inspiring so now we'll have a look at
thrusts from the first part of the 31
kuma Joel
section 1 2 3 demonstrates thrusting
empowering these are foundational
movements and appear quite often
inspiring although it might look quite
different the principles are still the
same the thrust in my view can sometimes
be used in the same way as a jab
sometimes it can be used to judge
distance other times it can connect with
the full body behind the thrust there's
much more in addition to these three
main attacks which can be found in
Aikido training I've already touched on
the Paris but there's also several other
movements that are similar to hassle and
others have come from the Kumu Jo and 13
dzhokhar if you've watched the previous
videos leave a comment and let me know
if there's anything else you've picked
up on I hope you enjoyed the series of
videos please remember to Like share and
subscribe as this helps the channel grow
and if you've got any questions feel
free to ask below